لقيادة الى بر الامان.
الروسي والدولة الروسية. هناك
ستكتب النهاية لعظمة روسيا
روسيا في تحسن مستمر مع زعيمها
الاول وبين احداث كارثية
تتوانى في اضعاف روسيا بكل ما
اوتيت من قوة. والاقتصاد الروسي
وجود قائد لبلاد بوتين ويا لها
من فوضى ستحدد مصير العالم وليس
الانتقام من الامريكان. وستشتعل
الحرب العالمية الثالثة. فضلا عن
الاتحادية كما كانت نهاية
الاتحاد السوفيتي من قبل. لكن
يخشى احدا في العالم. ولا يخاف
تجمع الاعداء من حوله. كل ذلك لا
وهناك قد يطمع المسؤولون الروس
بقيادة البلاد كل طرف يريد ان
المحافظة عليها من قبل قائد قوات
الردع النووية عندها يتم تسليمها
السلاح الا في حال تهديد وجودي
وسيادي للبلاد هكذا تقولها حكومة
البسيطة ويعد من اكثر الاسلحة
سرية في العهد السوفيتي. خبراء
مسؤولية بوتين الكبيرة الغرب
سيضغط بعقوباته وامريكا ايضا لن
استخباراتية لدول معادية للغرب
او دول صديقة لهم كاسرائيل او قد
سيتدحرج الى الهاوية دون رجعة.
والمتضرر الاول والاخير هو الشعب
يقدر الغرب على مجاراته واستطاع
رد عقوباتهم عليهم. لكن فيما لو
كما تسمى والتي يطلق عليها حلف
الناتو والخبراء العسكريون
سيعلم العالم انه سيتغير لا
محالة. لان بوتين لم يعد موجودا
بوتين اعاد للروس هيبتهم
وامجادهم هل يقبلون بنهاية كهذه
واستقرار مع بوتين قد يجبر روسيا
على الخيار الاصعب لكن حينها
ظلام دامس لانقطاع الطاقة
والكهرباء والعالم سيعيش حياة
التقارير الدولية ففي حال تم
اغتيال بوتين فقد نرى اليد
لم يستطع المجتمع الدولي منع
ذلك. وعندما غزا اوكرانيا لم
لخليفة بوتين. نهاية العظمة.
بوتين هو الزعيم الروسي الذي لا
يكتفي بذلك وقال اذا امر بوتين
بشن هجوم على الولايات المتحدة
يفقده صوابه ويمضي وفق خططه
والياته. فعندما قرر اخذ القرم
لقائدهم? بوتين يمضي وحيدا ولكنه
يحقق مكاسبه في كل شاردة وواردة.
والنفط من روسيا بحكم الفوضى
الحاصلة وستصبح قارة العجوز في
تم قتل زعيم الكرملين الاول فقد
ياتي من لا يستطيع حمل ثقل
قتل بوتين عندها سيتم تركيز على
الحقيبة وقد تقع في ايادي
اطلاق الاسلحة النووية الذي قد
يمحو الغرب عن بكرة ابيه. وان تم
روسيا وحسب. الحرب العالمية. اذا
ما قتل بوتين. فان السلطة ستذهب
والرئيس الجديد قد يفضل الانتقام
لبوتين ولشعبه. وفي الغالب سيكون
تقع في اياد الاستخبارات الصينية
او قد يتحفظ عليها الروس ويتم
لرئيس وزرائه ثلاثة اشهر ثم
يختار الروس رئيسا بديلا له.
لان بوتين يعرف انه لا احد سيفوز
في اي نزاع نووي. السيناتور لم
الغاب ياكل القوي الضعيف فقمح
روسيا لن يصل للعالم في ظل عدم
يقول. جراهام اضاف ان حرب عالمية
ثالثة لن تقع معتبرا انها خدعة
الحقيبة التي يحملها بوتين اينما
حل وارتحل. التي يوجد بها زر
فسيعمل بنفسه. انه رعب حقيقي يا
سادة. روسيا لن تستخدم هذا
في قتال مع قوات روسيا واوروبا
لن تستطيع شراء الطاقة والغاز
من شتاوفن بيرج في اشارة الى
الضابط الالماني كلاونس فون
القاتلة من بروتوس الذي كان
يعتقد قيصر انه سينقذه من
انها الفوضى. في حال تم قتل
بوتين. فقد تجتاح الفوضى روسيا
الميتة لروسيا وهي الة يوم
القيامة او ماكينة يوم القيامة
يمسك السلطة حينها لن تنعم
اوروبا بالامان فاوكرانيا ستظل
فان جنرالا سيقتله بالرصاص في
رأسه. اليد الميتة. بحسب بعض
من ساعة واحدة. وحتى لو لم يعد
هناك احد ليشغل هذا النظام
مسميات عدة لكن النظام الروسي
وحده الذي سينهي العالم اليا من
شتاوفن بيرج الذي فشلت قنبلته في
قتل ادل فيتلر عام الف وتسعمائة
الى الاسوأ اي ان القتال قد
يتوقف. حسنا دعونا نمضي كما
وناشطون ان النظام يمكنه تدمير
العالم في عشرات الدقائق اي اقل
واربعة واربعين. هنا يجيب
السيناتور الجمهوري لينسي جراهام
اشارة الى احد قتالة الحاكم
الروماني يوليوس قيصر? هل تعلمون
شخص اليه والرجل الثاني في
الدولة بعد قيصر. وذات يوم
ويتساءل الامريكان الا يوجد في
الجيش روسي كولونيل اكثر نجاحا
البالغ سبعة وستين عاما بان
القتال في اوكرانيا لن يتصاعد
اجتمعت حاشية قيصر واخرجوا
سيوفهم واخذوا يطعنونه. فهم قيصر
برصاصة في الرأس سيتم قتله. اليس
هناك من بروتوس في روسيا? يجب
على شخص ما في روسيا ان يصل الى
مستوى المسؤولية ويزيح هذا
الخونة. وقال مقولة خلدها
التاريخ حينها. حتى انت يا بروتس
ليلجأ لصديق روحه بروتوس. وهنا
كانت الصدمة. حين جاءت الطعنة
اطلس
من هو قيصر هذا? انه احد اعظم
القادة لروما? وكان لقيصر وزير
الغرب هذه? ماذا لو قتل بوتين او
تم اغتياله? ماذا لو انه مات
السيناتور الامريكي جراهام اليس
هناك من بروتوس في روسيا? في
يدعى بروتوس اغدق عليه قيصر
بالاموال والمناصب حتى صار اقرب
دون اي تدخل بشري. وبدون ان
يستطيع ان يوقفه كائن حي على وجه
موسكو. اوليس قتل رئيس البلاد
وزعيمها تهديدا لسيادة اي بلد؟
مقتل زعيمه وقائده الاول? منذ
عقود. امنية غربية. تساءل
المتحدة الامريكية وحلم الغرب
باسره. الجميع موت بوتين باي
السيناريو في عقله? وماذا عن
الشعب الروسي كيف سيتلقى خبر
موتا طبيعيا? يتساءل العالم في
حيرة الا يضع بوتين هذا
قالها السيناتور الامريكي والحال
ان هذه الغاية هي حلم للولايات
طريقة كانت فهل يتحقق ما يحلمون
به? لكن مهلا ماذا لو تحققت رغبة
الرجل. الوحيد القادر على تصويب
الامور هو الشعب الروسي. هكذا